[Music]
yeah i'm gonna do i have a whole new
swag for you today all right all right
my guest today
listen you're the you're the first
person to do this are we live right now
twice yeah first person to do this twice
my guest today welcome back mr toby
morris thanks for having me thank you
this is actually my third time because i
was on the original cast too oh okay
yeah yeah but i want to change it up
it's great to be there what's up man
you know what you know why you did that
yeah because he breaks my balls he says
that on all podcasts i'm pretty mellow
i'm a pretty mellow person when i do my
pop because
if i'm too hyper i'll talk too fast you
understand what i'm saying because the
real me is really hyper but i want him
on a podcast try to be professional and
take it slow and he's like every time
you leave you you all mellow but i'm
gonna reveal i'm gonna be really
animated today yeah what's up [ __ ] what
are we gonna talk about let's get into
it bro let's go what do you gotta think
what questions you got for me
you can be you
yo what's up we're doing you
the conversation i do want to have with
you
and we we've had this conversation off
the podcast
all right sharp professional go yeah no
you you're good you're good you're fine
you could be you
uh the ques
the battle
between oasis and coldplay yeah who won
that what do you who won that oasis you
did he did it he did a log
what do you call it it's an instagram
poll in the ig story i just sounded like
a boomer didn't i yeah dude it's a
[ __ ] very on brand
i did a poll and is it a poll according
to the people that follow me
particularly not people that follow you
they voted for oasis yeah because that's
what it is
but do you understand why
because i know you you try to you try to
go harder i know this battle i mean do
we have somebody here that can pull up
stats but i'm just telling you right now
that cold no no no no no no we're not
we're not talking we're not talking
about listen
oasis isn't abandoned anymore so we're
not like the statue keep trying to pull
up doesn't make any sense if they if
they if they book this show if people
come
would if oasis book the show would
people come yeah so then there's still a
way that they
broke up did they break up yeah they
i don't know about that
that's why you can't pull up those stats
because you don't know enough about
oasis i want to say if you look up who
sold more records who have more
consistent hits is coldplay i'm sorry
dude
i'm sorry i love oasis they don't oh i
mean i love the songs i know wonderwall
and a couple other ones oh
they have more songs
doesn't matter it's the same thing like
black flag versus minor threats the same
thing we have no it's not yes it is this
is different
i'm just understand right now that
coldplay sold more way more records i'm
not saying coldplay's a better band
how long is cool the songs are better
and coldplay is still a band of course
they sold more records that's why i'm
like that argument doesn't make any
sense okay how would they are they
together the same times or same years no
when it when did coldplay come around
what the late 90s yeah when their races
come around
90 uh 94 was when their first oh yes
oasis came after that i mean i no no
coldplay came after that you're correct
and people and people would if if
if oasis and coldplay were doing a show
down the street from each other
i guarantee you
more people are going to go to that
oasis show that okay
that's probably true because they
haven't played many years i get that i'd
be like a reunion show totally i get
that
i think even if they were still playing
well that's just your opinion that's
fine
we both have our opinions that's fine
it's because we love those bands so much
so obviously we want our band to win
yeah we want our band look look at you
you're so non-confrontational
non-competitive i'm just telling you we
just want both of our fans to do no we
do but but now black flag your favorite
band versus my favorite band minor
threat
see
right now no you didn't it's fine i'll
do it again today i swear why not do a
poll on that i did a long time ago i
tagged you in a [ __ ] i remember you know
it's true you tagged me in that yeah
it's true you know why listen okay that
makes sense you know i'll actually give
that if that's a fair one okay that's a
fair one i'll say
the reason being fairfax fair ones
fairfax favorite ones it's because of
the lineup change of black flag has
changed so damn much yeah you've had
five different singers for a black flag
okay yeah five different singers they
have keith morris
ron reyes dez kadena uh henry rollins
and then now mike valley correct five
different singers of course it's
something we just got ian that's it
that's all we need in that's it
and the rest of the homies that's all we
need you know and that's that's what so
that's fair i get it there's the minor
threat gave them a consistency even
though the albums were shorter sure
minor threat gave
the fans a consistency of minor threat
so you'd have to say minor threat if you
had to pick like yeah as far as albums
are yeah that's right all right i could
say that yeah that's so just this isn't
this to this man right here
do you have a related birthday happy
birthday birthday yeah uh henry rollins
happy bilated birthday to hr from bad
brains oh yeah that's right yep so how
you doing man i'm hanging in there yeah
you're hanging in there
that's good i mean i'm just saying man i
just had to i had to get that first
thing off my chest no i appreciate it
you know what i mean because i mean you
was going hard and i was saying coldplay
over oasis and i'm just trying to let
you know
i love doing it as well the fans will
[ __ ]
i know the fact that the fans they they
vote and they spoke and i listened and i
respect it i get it and then and here we
are yeah no dude it's been uh
we've been friends for
like a year year and some change
this is just a year it's been a
whirlwind dude isn't it crazy
listen i don't think i've ever had
anyone in my life that i've become
friends with that [ __ ] quick and i'm
like tight homies
like you're taking me on the road with
your band yeah uh
what uh
wait how many times have i seen you guys
a couple you saw us in arizona you saw
us in new york
you saw us
say there's only times dang twice only
twice that i've seen you guys wow that's
crazy
but you deep dive a lot of our videos
boston boston was one of my favorite
shows in here last year yeah all your
guys's stuff man yeah i've been obsessed
with this new york hardcore ever since
the day i'm surprised you don't want a
madbox shirt today i know right it's
probably in the water i go hard to paint
for madball yeah you're obsessed i'm
obsessed anytime you got freddy on the
phone i'm like oh that's freddy i mean
i'm ecstatic you know that one time seen
him changed your life in a way you know
it really did it really did you know
seeing ball
you know was like this thing of like
i don't know like i was like man i feel
this world
you know obviously from all the stories
you told me of course i built up to it
but like you know seeing it like happen
and like seeing it you know
i know it's probably a different energy
for when you know the early days of
course of all the stuff but
you still like
i don't know you can still feel it yeah
and all because all the stories you were
telling me about them are from the early
days hundred percent
super legit super amazing live man
untouchable man now why what listen i've
i've guest hosted for toby's podcast a
lot a lot right and he's had a lot of
great news musicians a lot of a lot of
great punk rockers on and literally
every time these punk rockers come on
they're always like man yeah we were
scared of you new york guys what the
[ __ ] is up with new york no i think i
think it was just back then also just
like there's a
a stigma about it um shout the stigma
but like there's this energy there's
also like you know urban legends of
certain people there's
a more uh rougher street energy it's
different i mean obviously california
bands like that they have it out here
venice and all that the dog town yeah
all that pretty
but you know but new york's different
east coast is different and a lot of the
bands came from different parts of
new york and from the streets and
there's this energy and this is kind of
look all that yeah cause it's different
you wonder why it's different it's like
okay like the warriors think about the
warriors that kind of thing but listen
like okay
because like okay remember east coast
west coast hip-hop totally that beef you
know what i mean
neither were were terrified of each
other no but when it comes to punk rock
and hardcore punk punk and hardcore
it seems like the west coast punks were
terrified
of you [ __ ] new yorkers it's crazy
yeah yeah but every single time i met
somebody or actually when they finally
met us
it was all love you know what i mean it
was just what they heard or there's
definitely stories and things definitely
happen and some a lot of the room is
pretty much are true like type of type
of mad ball and go to images
but i'm just saying like
for sure i mean
just just east coasters in general it's
a different energy the dancing the bands
the sound do you know what i'm saying
though gritty it's just a different
difference
the
third row or whatever this is to the to
the right of that right there
what's going on that's some new york
[ __ ] man
it's funny how my son's like i love card
i'm like man i was wearing card in like
91 92. everybody's got matt and hoya
meanwhile
so [ __ ] expensive it is now but like
we are at the army navy store though and
then in comparison to like a california
punk band it's a different [ __ ]
picture yeah you guys are posted up
chilling with pit bulls
on your heads but you can pull up a
suicidal picture from 80s and look hard
like that that's only of the california
bands yeah all you [ __ ] look
like that yeah you know why because it
was a mix between us loving hip hop and
loving hardcore and living in new york
at that time all the energy and
everything merged together like you put
pull up suicidal
yeah this is suicide picture suicidal
like an older one
i mean even that one's pretty sick the
top left one what one
no no
that one that's a classic man yeah
it's so west coast with the top yeah
yeah but that's just like you think
about it but like how many california
punk bands were like that
not many not men we love suicide in new
york but your whole your go you guys
whole aura
yeah like that like the whole yeah but
we were we we were deep in the hip hop
we were deep into hardcore so
a lot of that came together with onyx
and biohazard and the slam remix like
all that stuff kind of merged together
oh yeah like
what you call it um
um
public enemy and anthrax totally
right yep and then krs was on the sick
of it all his first record and then krs
one played his play the show we had it
was the secret all krs one show in new
york was amazing yeah man a lot of stuff
so yeah there was more of a crossover
with 100 so it was like
it kind of developed you guys's style
totally
fair to say yeah we would go to cbgb's
sunday matinee and that night my wife be
working at the limelight and my friend
brooklyn don't be working in the hip hop
room and we go to limelight that night
and listen hip hop shout out to
limelight you guys know about limelight
limelight you guys ever seen party
monster
amazing amazing movie yeah party monster
kids
no damn you got to see it type of club
kids and my wife was working there
during this whole time man so
there's this movie called party monster
mcconnell calkins in it macaulay tolkien
but so these are club kids right you you
can hit any one of those images
yeah my wife was a bartender during this
whole era so this whole era was a crazy
area
area
where like they were they would it was
like guys and girls dressed up like in
the craziest ways and they would go to
this bar in new york called limelight
and basically
would get
it was just a party scene yeah it was
just part drugs and heavy on drugs they
were doing like ketamine ecstasy cocaine
drinking all this stuff but it was like
the craziest night but then there was a
murderer and there was like yeah there
was a murder murderer so the leader of
the club kids was this dude named
michael aleg
right and michael alec was like the
[ __ ] do that put it all together
brother parties on put all the lines
parties together he was a crazy dude
crazy crazy [ __ ] dude and he ended up
killing his drug dealer right yes
dude kill this kind of an angel in the
car all right yeah cut them up
cut cut them up and put them in a box
there he's right there under the word
murder down there that's angel yeah yeah
so the movie party monster it's
incredible he wrote that do that the
angel the guy that said it's in the
middle down to the right yeah right
yeah that whole yeah so he murdered that
guy
yeah cut him yeah dude this is it's a
crazy it's pretty crazy craziest story
craziest movie
ever so what happened was
when everything got
taken down they came out here
that worked closely he's got a question
yeah you said it's a movie or so that's
a true story but they made a movie out
of it called parties it's a true story
sorry sorry so it's a true story and
they made a movie out of it called party
monster starring uh macaulay culkin and
seth green oh and they [ __ ] killed it
they killed this movie it's incredible
the accuracy and the way they pinpoint
and do everything is [ __ ] so based on
a true story yeah so they wanted this
guy so bad that every single person uh
that worked there including including
the place got audited so like my wife
had to get go down the irs office every
single person that worked and made tips
yeah all that got crazy when that murder
had happened yeah they're trying to get
everybody here yeah everybody who worked
there and stuff yes it's pretty crazy
that's a great story you gotta you gotta
watch the [ __ ] movie but h they also
had
another room in that in the church it
was a church on sixth avenue and there
was also another one where they had
shows some h2o's second shows with the
chromags at the limelight and my wife
was working there at the time really
uh-huh we had a lot of shows a lot of
great shows and then it was hypocritical
you shut down limelight after homie
murdered that dude i'm not sure about
that don't quote me on that but i'm
talking like 90
94 i played there or something at the
limelight yeah this episode is brought
to you by happy hippo happy hippo is a
kratom i just started taking it i
actually really like it a lot um it's
like keeps my brain going i use it right
before my shows right before doing a
podcast it's just helped me stay a lot
more alert and i like it because it's
healthy so when you go to happy hippo
herbals.com use promo code thick boy for
20 off for life you can use it as many
times as you want again promo code thick
boy for 20 off boom
yeah but it was just a whole different
vibe different energy in new york and
like that's what i'm saying there was
like a hardcore show one room then there
was like this kind of vibe then there
was a hip-hop room it was already
different there's so much culture
like yeah so there's where like it was
the melting pot of all cultures that's
why i was and it's weird because like i
feel like uh
everybody messes together but everybody
has their
like what they are
it's like oh i i'll i'll come kick you
with you but i am a hip-hop dude
yeah yeah but i feel like for us like me
freddie all of us
we we went to hip hop and went and went
to hardcore so like we were rocking
carhartt we were rocking
different styles that weren't the
hardcore look yeah did you know what i
mean yeah for sure you know it was just
in new york though yeah it was dope to
get a hint of like i mean i was
literally there for [ __ ] less than 24
hours but it was cool to like go there
and like walk around and eat a slice of
[ __ ] pizza in new york you know it
actually was cool and then to like see
like a new york
show like hardcore show
like that you know that i've never like
seen before if it wasn't a pandemic
would have been a different show but
it's still a great show i wish you a
longer time there next time we play or
bring you back for a longer time like we
can walk around low east side your
favorite words
and we can show you the different spots
where you all hung out and stuff you
know what i mean i don't know i don't
know why i [ __ ] gig so hard over this
[ __ ] i don't know why i liked her you
really you're really connected to it i
just
you know i don't know i don't know what
it is and i haven't pinpointed it out
like because i can [ __ ] tell you all
day
why connect with rollins and [ __ ] like
that but i i literally can't tell you
why i'm beyond rollins now i know you
love him but you're like in the map
level we're just like in a different
level of like hardcore now like now
you're listening you don't think i love
rollins you do but now you're like
trapped in the rice
lord and savior no you do i know i know
he has your back i know he's there for
you
but i'm just saying but you're like deep
dive into other things i love that yeah
yeah yeah
yeah oh dude yeah you could show me a
lot of stuff man like i mean well like
because it's like all uh the bands that
i've been listening to right now have
been influenced by
your guys's uh friends yeah yeah your
specific world that you come from
totally the specific hardcore world so
it's actually pretty dope and like to
hear it like kind of like evolve
into
the next generation this next generation
of fans it's like dope here meanwhile
you still got all the [ __ ] you know
og hardcore bands that are still touring
and still you haven't done a full tour
yet no it's been two years last month
yeah no i thought it was 2019. no it's
been two years
uh but just january we said january
before january 2020 yeah was the last
time you had a full tour two yeah now
we're going back to england hopefully in
uh april no we're doing it right now we
saying [ __ ] everybody with this [ __ ] we
are you know everything's open over
there we're going bro you're going over
there you're going too yeah i'm going
you're going to enjoy by yourself though
i'm not going by myself okay i'm going
with a buddy okay nice yeah i'm going
with brenda's brother oh you found
somebody just as obsessed with oasis as
you it's
impossible
his brother loves him like you do or he
doesn't know what show he's going to oh
he probably thinks he's going to a
coldplay show in their hometown you know
i think this will be the first
fair one fight
on
chappelle's world dude
i'll miss you on this show
amazing
no you're really going with somebody
else that's you you don't know anyone
obsessed with oasis just as much as i am
adam blake loves him he like i think he
loves stone roses too because he's from
england but he loves he loves oasis not
like you
not like you like you know everything
about them like more than adam and he's
from england and this don't rose at you
he's got a lot of knowledge on that too
as well i mean those are great [ __ ]
bands yeah you know
but you ain't going you're gonna sit
here and diss me on my podcast i'm not
but i think people i think people trip
out when they see that you like oasis
you know what i'm saying
we were at green table yeah and that
dude was like
some dude came up to me he was like yo
yo yo i know who you are i see you
around all the time he goes i got to ask
you something are you really an oasis
fan like straight up
he came that aggressive didn't he yeah
and i said bro who you talking to he
goes cause i'm gonna waste his fan and i
was like and i just showed the tattoo
live forever homie yeah shout out to
that dude that dude was actually really
really cool he was nice he was like he
goes okay okay i had to call you out you
know because some people they they front
you know what i mean like where's your
tattoo bro also of all bands i confront
on why would it be oasis yeah
why would you go
go so hard for them not really all bands
why would it be them yeah they're not
even an american band
they're british i know it's so crazy man
you love it i love it i mean it's it's
over you don't hope they help you find
out someday that you're like their
number one fan
i think they already know yeah okay
you're you're on the radar it's like
neil diamond uh like out have you ever
seen steven silverman yeah they love
they love neil diamond that's how i am
they'd be so sick if you were on the
radar one day they they knew about they
knew about chipotle or something that'd
be kind of sick
somebody that follows you and listens to
your pod it's got to spread the word
somehow get it out to them you know whoa
if you can meet them when you go out
there in june they'll be so sick oh do
you
you know people would pass out at
michael jackson concerts yeah that'd be
me
so you wouldn't want to meet him i'd be
like oh
would you not want to meet him yeah
i would love would you be so sure could
you ask for a photo would you just shake
their hand i would like a photo
i probably wouldn't be posting because
this is i would just keep it to myself
this is no dissed oasis
but rumor has it for whatever what i've
seen in the area
you better watch what you've about to
say what i've seen on the internet it
seems like they might kind of be
not so not or jerks and you know maybe
break balls or you know i'm saying like
they fight with each other a lot right
that's the online world toby okay and
that is not a real i just hope to be
nice to you because i've met a lot of
people in my life here was all the
doctor i wish i never met him then i met
something i'm so stoked that i met him
and so there might be there might be
somebody that it might be somebody you
don't want to meet and just stay a fan
you know what i'm saying it happens to a
lot of people
uh i know rollins i was i was nervous to
meet rollins i mean yeah i was super
nice i was kind of i met him once too i
was kind of nervous to be honest yeah i
was i was i was terrified not scared but
just like is he going to be cool or not
because you want you want to still love
them if they if they weren't cool i'd i
mean i'd be like oh that's sorry i mean
it's kind of well known that they can be
[ __ ]
so i would i wouldn't be
i don't think i'd be uh
so you know if they were addicted to you
you still love them 100
you won't be a tad bit sad no because
it's like i already know that's how they
are i know
yeah but you you so who wouldn't love me
okay okay so how do you know how you
know that wait one second how do you
know that's how you know that's the way
they are because the internet oh this
[ __ ]
i'm just saying you never met him
they could be totally cool to you i met
chris martin the most amazing moment of
my life who's chris martin i walked home
i almost floated home i i was emotional
i don't give a [ __ ] i met chris martin
he stopped he gave he took his pin off
he gave it to me we had words i showed
him my tats he he's like can i have a
hand he gave you a pin yeah he wears his
pin this love pin it says non-profit
organization and he always has a pin on
he gives it to every person he meets
usually is he vegan
he was at a vegan spot
um
and so he said he goes can i have a hug
and he asked me for a hug no he did it
yes he goes i show him test goes bro can
i have a hug i show him both my tats he
goes do you want to get when i get a
photo i'm like yeah and then there was a
dude standing next to him i was like is
that rick o'kasick i found out later was
what's his face everybody freaked out
when i didn't know who he was he's got
black hair he's tall he's skinny he you
wouldn't expect to be hanging out with
chris martin russell brandt no he wrote
a bunch of soundtracks people love this
guy he might have to google him and he
wears black he looks like rickard kasich
people who love him
he like his dark he writes soundtracks
and tv shows
he was with him man he's hanging
no was standing right next to him
waiting for him and i was like i i
didn't even care what that was it was it
was chris martin it was with him i
forgot his name he hangs out with him he
writes songs he produces music
dan smith loves him he's going to kill
me
he's got black hair looks like rick
o'casic typing rick okay he just dresses
on black and
maybe i could you're gonna be so bummed
he'd probably like him too okay anyway
he was white he was with him he looks
like rick okay yes he was with him and
he stopped and gave me a moment it was
so beautiful dude he looks like he looks
like that and he's a songwriter people
gonna be so bummed maybe they see this
podcast
he's younger yeah
you look alike write songs
anyway he stopped and like that guy was
waiting to get waiting to get a whip
with him and he gave me like five
minutes so it was awesome it was mad
cool oh and then there's something
you're talking about and then there's
some no no wait
oh the bad seeds and the bad seeds
is name in the bad seeds
the name of the bad seeds nick cave it
was that game oh got it you got it got
it got it in the cave yeah yeah yeah
pull up nick cave yeah yeah i didn't
know who it was
yeah yeah it was tim i know right
exactly
and so i didn't know it was similar it's
pretty good and so i don't know if that
guy was bummed i didn't recognize him
but i just saw chris and i was like oh
[ __ ] like bumped into each other
literally dude it was a craziest moment
mad cool where where were you at it's
crossroads oh yeah crossroads and chris
i was going in he was coming out didn't
chris live here yeah and he held the
door for me yeah he lives in like malibu
i'm not saying where he lives because
i'm a fan but yeah he
i was going in he was coming out yeah
and i was like yo
i just got to tell you what i said what
i said and he's like oh my god come here
mate pull me to the side give me a hug i
want to do a photo i looked over there
look rick okay bootleg was hanging out
and dakota fanning was it that was his
girl that's a girlfriend she was there
to go to fannie yeah they're dating yeah
really yeah brother get out look it up
homie i just wanna fanny i love town
girls i love her i just saw a photo
within valentine's day together or
something what come on bro they're
married no they're just hanging out
there with their boyfriend girlfriend
crazy right that was just my moment so
you felt that you were like
she's not dating chris martin yeah she
is homie i think you got it wrong i
don't
it's not dakota fanning yes it is homie
johnson
oh yeah dakota johnson
johnson
50 shades of grey bro
oh her dad's uh
her mom's manly griffith no not andy
griffin
what if it's the mom
and the dad is uh badass was he macgyver
badass
john johnson okay
so those two i see why you got andy
griffin because you were thinking don
knotts i you said andy griffith i said
melanie griffith is the mom i'm sorry
this episode's wild
um anyway back to like meeting your
heroes
dude i met jay-z i was so shook there's
so many people made i was so shook what
about madonna you remember but i was at
cbgb's it was really quick
i just happened to have a photo of her
in my wallet because i was obsessed with
her and she signed it i still have it
you still have that photo yeah that she
signed yeah i have it really yeah that
was that was awesome because it was a
cypress obuya tribe show at cbgb's what
was she doing there i know it's the
night before lollapalooza and everybody
was there hanging out she's playing
lollapalooza no she just came to hang
out she came with her manager freddie
demand when's the last time she's toured
or anything no man
i don't know
right yeah think about it
it's pretty crazy i haven't seen madonna
like
hit a stage in a minute that'd be
awesome to see that she would [ __ ]
sell out a tour it'd be cool to see her
now like like in her 60s performing oh
should kill it yeah because you cause
you could tell like
i mean i don't know it's the online
world but you could tell by her her post
that she still she still has that energy
like she still has energy actually no
when she was on uh what you call it look
at casey gonna go to that [ __ ]
instagram uh when she was on i hope you
should go to instagram or not man and
why you don't want to see that booty
if i don't get into that man
why i don't know it's just ladonna
instagram
oh yeah she was still killing i love
madonna i just i don't know
you know you haven't done the way you
see madonna and loved madonna you know
what i mean like
next to what 65 or something um she
can't be 65. she looks good
i think she's like uh you say she looks
different yeah i haven't seen madonna in
a minute well there you go she's gotta
be like at least six i wanna take you
there in the midnight out i can feel you
about um
who is somebody you like to meet your
pal you haven't met yet
besides oasis yeah
um
oh oh snoop in a ice cube
did you watch the halftime show yeah yes
what'd you guys think i loved it i just
wish it was longer i love it i know yeah
i wish it was longer i know if they did
like a big ass tour again that's what
people are pushing for now they did the
upper spoke tour
yes you went to the open smoke
tournament a couple times he didn't do
anything he's tr he's straight edge yeah
he got high as [ __ ] yeah the whole arena
was full of weed it was i saw in
connecticut and in long island it was it
was yeah you went backstage yeah my nice
ice cube because did you get backstage i
got invited to go back there because we
just they knew who you were because you
did the
so on priority records there was a
compilation uh rap right it was like
rock bands covering rap songs and we
covered ice cube it was a good day yeah
and so i got hooked up to go back to
meet ice cube and stuff meet him because
he had heard the song
oh really he was cool as [ __ ] he was
cool he was pretty serious it was pretty
like of course had dudes with them and
[ __ ] it was pretty quick but it was cool
yeah that's the lynch mob bro i know man
i know and i met snoop too because we
were both label mates in 2001 on mca
and i was invited to a video shoot he
was doing somewhere in l.a and i pulled
up but i brought this huge
this huge snoop dogg portrait that was
printed out for me to get signed and i
carried that with me i was such a nerd
dude and i got to go inside with the
shooting um the video he had his he was
drinking out of the pimp cup like
that was the thing that back then yeah
smoking weed and then and there was all
smoke in the room and i walked in there
and they said come on he's going to meet
i got to sit down the couch and shake
his hand and he said like some [ __ ] like
fascism that's what he's really talking
fishes all that yeah yeah he said
something like she doesn't want to give
me a pound we took a photo that was it
it was pretty awesome but he was nice
yeah he's super nice
so high though those are two two guys
that uh because those those are like my
those are my top two favorite rappers
because uh ice cube and uh
snoop yeah and so i would love like
i'm gonna keep throwing that energy out
there it'll definitely happen it's a
small world we're in l.a bro it's like
yeah you know i really want them on here
open sick of ice cube came out man like
the other day in the halftime that would
be really sick man you know how 50 got
to do like half a song uh-huh like ice
cream could come out you know that'd be
really awesome it would be so [ __ ]
dope man but that should be a tour that
tour would crush oh it would be insane
that could be like an arena or a stadium
not about stadium but a pretty big that
would be a [ __ ] nah because you got
to think that yeah that could be a
stadium i say that because you got to
think we have our generation that [ __ ]
with them and now this younger
generation yeah [ __ ] with those like
you your son's starting to listen to ice
cube
yeah he didn't know
he didn't realize that no vaseline was a
diss track
it's true isn't that funny yeah then he
would listen to lyrics he's like oh [ __ ]
he's dissing the guys he used to [ __ ]
yeah being a group with no that's true i
think it'd be really big plus eminem on
his own can crush something that big
all the doctor snooze on their own
kendrick huge and obviously dr dre
doesn't tour anymore so it's like yeah
yeah he hasn't toured in a minute i
think his last tour was the up and smoke
tour yeah
i'm sure
i mean after his divorce i'm sure it
couldn't help
no i'm saying i'm just saying like a lot
of money was lost i really know it was
on the internet
well a lot of money for us a lot of
money for us yeah to him he's like
no i know but i do think that's easy if
they're still down the tour i think they
could kill it i think they still could
perform and go off like they did they
looked all look great oh yeah they all
look good i think that they could really
what did while seeing a [ __ ] quick walk
crazy super bowl that was that was he
was like dude
that was amazing that's mine right there
that was the story
that's like that's a historic time you
know what i mean oh there was it was
historically it was it was dope for la
because it was it was such an la thing
and then la wins and then la wins on
time
you know like yeah it was a it was
actually a dope [ __ ] moment
i love the way music can [ __ ]
translate to [ __ ] anything yeah you
know what i mean yeah like like think
about it anytime anybody does anything
like
like football players they're listening
to [ __ ] music they're warming
themselves up yeah people that are going
to work out people that are driving to
work people
it's so much of it i love how every time
somebody drops a new record lebron james
is listening to it and promoting it and
they always post it the last couple
records i've seen drake kanye the new
nas lebron's always doing something
where he's listening to it and promoting
it almost every time it's so cool
training to it it's awesome dude there's
not too many things that i look like
that i say i would love to be
um i kind of just like do the things
that i love and hopefully they
you know become this big thing or
whatever but i would love to be that
person
for
music to where it's like oh i listen to
it and i [ __ ] with it and then people
and then people are like oh chappelle
listen to this yeah i would love to be
that person because i'm such a fan of
music yeah that like to have to have
that kind of like
i don't want to call it power but just
sort of have that kind of like strength
to be able to like you do put that out
there too you do you do you do because
you are a comedian that wears punk rock
shirts and that's how i found you so
people like what the [ __ ] is a fugazi
i'm sure people have looked into that
when i wear when i wear a fugazi shirt
to shows
i think like there was some italian dude
he was like oh yeah yeah
i was like no it's uh it's a band yeah
but then but then he might looked into
it i'm insane
you are influencing people because you
are wearing these shirts that's what i'm
saying yeah i want to have i want to be
able to have that type of information
dude do you think people didn't look up
gbh or some other bands you know what
the [ __ ] it was a shirt you're wearing
and it's always a band it's totally
happening just by you representing it
and wearing it and talking about it you
know people want to see what you're into
you know what i mean you definitely do
it bud
no lebron level yeah that's what i'm
saying but yeah i would love i would
love to be on that level yeah you know
to be so to where like because like okay
it's different like people look at the
records but like to help the records
success
you know what i mean to help them to
help people like go to they've done that
like like that's what i love about like
what i do with chappelle's world like i
wanted to be that thing that
people like uh like the trl days where
people would go on trl and it would do a
big thing for them or you know they were
going what was the head bankers ball you
know yeah you know uh what was it 120
minutes that uh
mtv will turn out you have something to
eat yeah all these things that like you
know that
really did a lot for musicians
you know before the internet you know i
would love to have that like this
eventually be able to grow
to that and i love like what's dope is
like i have non musical guests on here
as well which is dope because you get to
hear their perspective of what they like
and what you know gets them stoked on
music because i'm always curious of that
because i'm like i'm a guy like you know
yeah i just started a band and stuff
like that you know first show march 26th
what's the band called can you say it no
we don't have a name
we're struggling okay you have a show
booked already with no name i mean no
not impressive yeah not for nothing
that's a lot of stories like on vh1
stories like we didn't have a name we
just had a show we jumped on we played
the show then somebody said something
that was the name yeah
dude
i don't know what to do he could just
come to you at the last moment
time 35
is that a good name i just can't have
you have you uh
have you ever met anybody that didn't
listen to music like oh i'm not inspired
by music on the same music i really
never met anybody no but i know they're
out there there are those people i want
to talk to yeah those are people i'm
interested in listening to daliah right
yeah yeah yeah he does this
music he's like actively does it wow
he said like he was that fight companion
and that's what i want to have him on
i'ma have him on yeah he's driving him
all the way here and was like i didn't
listen to music he's like i just have my
thoughts and like i think of [ __ ] yeah
wow that's pretty amazing man yeah just
to be so in tune and that's all you need
is just yourself but he's also die-hard
tupac fans he's he's a die-hard tupac
fan okay so okay so there's music there
there's no music with tupac's catalog
listen forever you're good if you can
just listen to tupac that's it
okay
that's this one has one island that's
why you're one uh artist on the island
or whatever or in real life too doesn't
it yeah yeah oh yeah just [ __ ]
that's crazy that's crazy yeah you don't
have to go anywhere it's the only thing
he's got
he doesn't listen to music that's crazy
bro yeah
it's i couldn't imagine life without
music i know every day we listen to
music at least every day every day every
day you and i are listening to music
it's crazy right
i don't know if that helps our mind or
like we hear one word or one thing or we
get i don't know i don't know what it
it's just soundtrack to our lives yeah i
guess it just helps with my feelings and
my emotions
yeah uh like a lot you know like when
you're sad what are you listening to
when i'm sad what i listen to
when i'm sad does chappelle makes you
get sad
uh
i don't know that it's okay to show milk
showing your podcast
you're a sensitive teddy bear don't
front it's sad
okay i can google it yeah can you google
snap
i don't think i know
okay when you get angry or stressed
stressed huh
this guy thinks this guy thinks he's
like not human he's a robot what is the
latin
you use it in a sense can you use it
come on come on
what do you listen to
yeah or something i don't know i don't
even know what i would listen to if i
was sad okay
probably like when you like when i'm
angry yeah you're stressed out is it
like rollins or angry and stressed out i
actually try not to listen to any of
that stuff yeah because it's aggressive
because it's aggressive so you want
something to mail you out like i have
like i have to like uh
like if i'm angry it's definitely not
that because all that's going to do is
just make me even more okay so maybe
like third eye blind so i have to be
like i have to be happy to listen to
that music got you does that make sense
yeah yeah you do something opposite so
what do this like third eye blind or no
thank you abyss or no because you know
what three doors
like i don't i don't think i listen to
music when i'm sad because
music makes me happy
okay does that make sense yeah okay do
you listen to you listen to um do you
listen to
podcasts i actually don't
dude
are we postings
i'm cutting that out i'm cutting that
out
it's getting cut out no i don't i don't
if there's an
episode yes the way i treat podcasts is
the same way i treat movies okay going
going to the movies but you never do but
i know i never do
i would i really have to be interested
in the [ __ ] episode or in the movie
or some type of whatever the episode may
be i have to be so [ __ ] interested
okay what's the last movie you saw in
the theater [ __ ]
i think i know what it is too i can
remember what
just disco
probably when i uh equalizer two yeah
that was it okay yeah yeah yeah yeah we
went to the uh how many years ago
uh chris shaw i was like 2018 29 wow
last movie you went to so you don't love
movies nope bad boys three right before
the panda okay
and we watch good fellas together for
the first time
doesn't matter
what we're saying and now i'm saying the
movie movies you never saw good fellas
since you last year which is all good
still love you
and you know what all my new york
friends
i ain't scared of you [ __ ] just
because i recently saw a badass movie
all right i'll [ __ ] everybody up
you're you're i won't but your recent
new york friends
your recent your rap report was
disgusted oh yeah
yeah uh he told ravenport i had never
seen good he was like in shock i've
never seen someone hold a still face
for 10 minutes straight just [ __ ]
it's just part of life to see that it is
it is
and it's and it's actually fair that i
get to look because i'm such a like
godfather's like in my top five yeah you
know the the godfather so like
you know it makes sense that like
i get hated on if i hadn't seen you
showing max boys in the hood that was
awesome yeah oh yeah for all those og
gangster movies that's minutes to
society after that i love all that [ __ ]
american me is the next it's great all
american me is dope too heavy that one
yeah that one's heavy yeah it's crazy
when he actually moved to l.a
and you're you're in this world that you
grew up watching movies about like
living on the east coast and watching
all those movies you know what i mean
being like intrigued by it like is it
really like that what's going on then
you move out here
shit's real oh it's so real nice
go to iced teas instagram
the other day this is the realest [ __ ]
we're living in los angeles we need
movies
bro you don't realize it go so good as
uh instagram yeah it kind of went viral
i think the other day yeah instagram a
bunch of people reposted it and talking
about it
uh
because that looks pretty pretty wild
right now man instagram what is this
instagram it's just iced tea though
isn't it yeah that's it final level
that's him
the top top top
yep iced tea verified yeah
so scroll down wow everybody took it
down bro no he didn't okay toby
slow your roll go to that far right we
post a lot okay down there
yeah
so he said super bowl weekend
not a threat just a warning
young rappers coming to l.a for the
super bowl weekend la has over 50 000
active gang members make sure you play
it safe it's the wild wild west
jack damn this is a public service
announcement i know right yes
but you know what's so funny this [ __ ]
was like
growing up before i before i had ever
been to la or anything like that and
obviously listen to the snoop dogg i see
you you hear them talk about it you hear
them
when you move to l.a that is a real
thing it is i go man i probably
shouldn't be wearing blue in this
neighborhood right now it is man it's
that [ __ ] real
yeah but it's cool but i mean obviously
if you just mind your p's and q's
totally kind of just like you know
just don't i mean yeah just i was
you have your ways of navigating it i
was carrying a bag of groceries home
from trader joe's in the middle of the
afternoon i had no license i moved it
from new york i've never driven my whole
life so i didn't have a license like a
year and a half riding my bikes
everywhere yeah and this car posted it's
like a low rider car puts out there's
this one dude in the car
and he's and he's like he's like yo man
i looked over and said where are you
from now i'm from new york he's like all
right and he kept dropping he's drove
away it was like a moment like in a
movie dude yeah where are you getting
checked i got checked i was tatted up at
shorts on all that he's like where are
you from i was like from new york all
right
now it was crazy man yeah i feel like
la's spread out enough though that you
can avoid trouble whereas yeah and i was
on the breyer in third bro like by the
trader joe was like oh yeah they're
trying to choose me
that area is so nice and then
yeah it was crazy
he probably just left trader joe's
himself you ever thought about that no
but it was definitely a moment ago he
was picking up some cauliflower knocking
and just checking dudes definitely won't
be like fully tattooed and moving out
here oh just like the perspective of
that being fully tatted yeah it makes
sense i mean you like
and as obviously like you'll see
some of the gang members around and you
see him he's like i don't i don't want
to look that way because new york is
different new york is like different
boroughs
different crews different neighborhoods
yeah the gang culture here is like i
mean i mean it's definitely happening
there now but when i was there it wasn't
like that was just definitely like
inaudible different vibe just different
neighborhoods even my dad was telling me
you know he was like yeah i mean my dad
i mean
my dad's vacation spot is compton by the
way so wow okay yeah that's uh that's
where he goes
only place he feels comfortable when he
comes but the neighborhood the
neighborhoods here can drastically
change yeah
pretty fast in new york you know like
the bronx you know east new york harlem
different spots you know areas you know
that are you know what i'm saying back
then yeah it's definitely different now
flatbush and bushwick and all that stuff
brooklyn but
yeah it's interesting but yeah but
actually this you know we're getting
back to moving out here and
living in the world of the movies that
you saw you know yes it's pretty
interesting ain't no joke i love i love
cali i love it um so now toby i do this
part where i've added to my
show to close out with i like to do
rapid questions okay okay
favorite band
just one band
i said what i said uh coldplay oh
favorite concert
oh man concert or show
concerts up in smoke a show is cbgb's
any show at cvgb's is like okay okay
okay so a concert's like a concert
so when we do concert i'll say
up and smoke tour that was your favorite
concert you've gone to yeah ooh damn
favorite
favorite show that you've played
favorite show that we played
was playing bogota colombia for the
first time
so surreal people at the airport people
dudes dudes came out
like and like made like a human wall and
protect surrounded my band as we went
from the van into the venue sold out
show in columbia people were screaming
all hardcore kids
so emotional again it's the best show of
our life it was in uh
bogota colombia and i think that was 2
000
and maybe you don't quote me on maybe i
think my flyer like 2010 or 11. okay
amazing beautiful experience going to
south america the first time but
columbia that one show was like it was
surreal dude my wife was with me it was
it was crazy man you getting goosebumps
yeah i was yeah and the show was bananas
sweat on the walls people diving off the
balconies is just i could vision the
whole show
crazy man it was really wonderful it's
so fun
i did show the guys your
uh
like one of your sets
um like one of you like
one of your live sets yeah uh you guys
playing nothing to prove and they were
just like what the hell's going on they
didn't know like that's how y'all got
down
i showed brendan nice uh when we were
was that the philly footage from this is
hardcore yes yeah i love that see i love
that i love that festival too um
favorite joe favorite album
uh favorite album of my own album or
just any others or sorry uh we'll do
would any album like that you like and
then one in your favorite album of your
band
um timeless classic that i never get
sick of listening to is nauseomatic one
of my favorite records of all time and
my favorite album i've ever made there's
nothing to prove
those are my two i knew it
those are my two wait wait okay i got
one more for you and then we'll give
them to them with the girl record
favorite favorite song
to play live
favorite song to play live
dang i still love playing guilty by
association man i love that song i love
what it represents not just because you
sang on it the energy of it the crowd
participation what it represents still
to me yeah um and i have to go if i have
to go two five year plan too first song
ever written damn the whole crowd's
singing that's beautiful the energy of
that i i don't know
i have to have those two yeah
all right make sure we covered
everything this is my third second time
on every time we get in the car i mean
we should have said something though i'm
pretty sure you'll [ __ ] be back on i
mean you're just a [ __ ] you're like
yeah you are my podcast i haven't done
your podcast in a minute but uh what
yeah no that guy's coming on as a co are
they coming on though coming out co-host
yeah
as doing work
as doing labor yeah you know we did it
we did a four-hour episode with you
found a lot to talk about
all right so now we're going to do a
playlist apologies in advance for the
spelling
[Laughter]
yeah apologies for this
you can't spell um so
i can't spell i don't know any of these
bands i can't spell them i know i can
spell but i get the name so we're going
to do just a playlist we'll make for the
that represents this episode
um
let's do
i'll start off first
i'll go
i'll go
damn
oh since we talked about him and i i
want people to know more about
this [ __ ] band um we'll do we'll do a
trapped under eyes sec
song which one do i [ __ ] want
uh let's do
damn there's so many good ones let's do
trapped under ice back stabbed
is this any kind of uh one any any any
it just represents us it represents our
vibe for the
so it's the soundtrack to this episode
soundtrack to this episode would be
damn man we got a lot of uh songs from
up and smoke i would do i would do uh
ice cube good day
good one
because we talked about that and covered
that
uh i'll do
snoop dogg she isn't it
snoop dog
um
you got that you actually spelled that
right actually i wonder if he did
i do eminem mockingbird mockingbird
let me see if he [ __ ] smelled that
right
he did she isn't it right he's fine yeah
how snoop spells it yeah
she isn't it because he rolled the dice
on it listen i know k listen you don't
know casey i'm gonna have to say
i think she's right he does feel right
yep how hard is shiznit bro it's good
gosh what you're doing you can't even
speak words i know
let's do
let's see what else did we talk about
yeah we talked a lot about the west
coast stuff you want to make it a um
i'll do kendrick lamar
damn
and i'll do dna
damn oh she didn't perform anything off
of um the damn record it was very
interesting the other night
i can't wait he has any record out it's
got it off uh he didn't perform
to pimp a butterfly yeah and also um
uh good kid bad city yeah um okay i want
to say for the bands we mentioned and
talking about
new york and
i'm going to do
um
i want to do a band that people were
scared of back then the california bands
were scared of so let's do like let's do
gnostic front
uh anthem live uh live at cbgb's anthem
this is to
a gnostic front yo this would be a good
one for you bro agnostic friends
[Laughter]
can we just do live at cbgb's that'll
cover everything people know yeah
meanwhile i can't put that on the
playlist but go ahead
i'll choose one song from that you could
pick your big anthem from that anyway go
ahead um
since i did trapped under ice and his
current band is angel dust this dude
named justice shout out to justice uh
dope dude he's done toby's podcast and
stuff no no so his other guy so angel
dust and for the s on uh dust you got to
put a dollar sign
from justice no no no no no no no no no
no no the band's caught an angel it's
called angel dust
dollar sign
and then the song i'll do off for angel
does guys there's so many good ones
um
probably do
let's do turn up my
let's do
rectify we'll do rectify great band dude
great great band
next up
we're going to put um
dre and snoop
deep cover
that's a big car incognito [ __ ]
first song they did together you know
that
uh
i'll do
i'll do mad ball
oh [ __ ] i'll do uh i know it's gonna be
let's do damn violence
dude
i almost said at the same time it's a
perfect one
not knowing that you're worth sending me
was
me that's one of the hardest songs ever
man hard
dang uh your turn how many do we have
casey nine 1999
um
i'm gonna do
onyx biohazard bionics
we talked about that earlier so
biohazard yep and then the song is
called bionics
that is a remix
of the song slam
by biohazard and i was in that video
no you know
you do
i'm in that video slam yeah i'm in i'm
in that video i'm also in that video i'm
also in the remix bionic so it's b i o
n y x
bionics you almost had it
but
i'll do there we go
um
since we'll we'll close it off with
these last two we'll do one one more
piece i'll go oasis
head shrinker
damn
one word but it's a lot easier when the
band you this is spelled on the wall for
me that's right
this is such a weird mix
i'm gonna go for you gotta you gotta you
gotta
since i didn't you gotta i'm going for
coldplay all right me and my son's
favorite song it's called charlie brown
emo as [ __ ] this song um
toby you are performing
march 5th march 5th at garden amp in
southern california with pennywise with
pennywise march 5th uh i'll be there
will be performing one song yeah i'll be
performing one song the last 30 seconds
of a song
i'll be performing and then also i'll be
february 25th and 26th which is next
week
i'll be in kansas city missouri at the
comedy club of kansas city i got friends
10th you better tell them to come hold
up see your power hold up march 10th and
march 12th i'll be in springfield
missouri at the blue room comedy club
and then april 8th and april 9th i'll be
in salt lake city at wise guys comedy
club and then may 12th one nighter at
stand up live my home uh home city so uh
tickets at chapelac.com
grab them do all the great stuff and yes
come to my shows boom
and toby thank you brother thank you man
yeah i appreciate it we should take
we're going to take notes in the car for
the next time i come because then we
miss something for sure more deep dives
we got a lot of stories bro we got too
many
it's fine though because we're with each
other every day i know we we'll be back
we'll be back all right
thank you
you